one very excited to have you here
um just uh for the audience hello
welcome to Pi data Global 2022. my name
is Dave Gerson and I'm very happy to be
hosting the session
um along with my co-organizer Chong Shen
um and without further Ado I wanted to
introduce DJ Patel he's currently a
board member of devoted Health a senior
fellow at the Harvard Belfor Center
an advisor to venrock Partners and is
most famous for being the first Chief
data scientist of the United States of
America
we're incredibly excited to have him
here
thanks Dave uh I'm glad to be here uh so
I guess the way we're going to do this
is I'm going to give a a little bit of a
talk uh about something I haven't shared
a huge amount publicly but I'm excited
to kind of share it and then hopefully
we'll be able to take a whole bunch of
questions from the the community and and
talk through whatever topics people want
does that sound cool Dave
sounds like a plan awesome all right so
I want to take us back a little bit of
ways to March 14th 2020. and so uh what
what is really special about this day
more than anything else to me is that
it's Pi Day uh and on this Pi Day this
particular pie day as I was seeking out
pies something else was actually taking
place in the world
and that thing that was really taking
over the world if maybe you remember
really was covid and at that point in
March on March 14 2020 we roughly had in
uh across the world we're only 65 deaths
and about 9
815 cases here in the San Francisco Bay
area we had two ships that had docked uh
that were passenger cruise ships there
was a lot of debate about what to do
with those Personnel to do with the
people that were coming off those do you
quarantine them all these kind of these
these uh questions where we really
didn't have a lot of information
how many of us that were in the that had
done work in epidemiological uh setting
sectors we're looking at this and
getting predominantly worried I know
many of the community out here many of
you have actually worked on this and and
and I want you to think back to that
moment when you were at on March 14th in
2020 and think about where we were as a
community we probably still as a
committee we're just working on our open
source projects our different different
areas all those different things and we
were suddenly coming to this realization
that the world was about to change
and for me one of the big things and a
lot of this is documented in Michael
Lewis's book premonition
but I want to take you behind the scenes
of what actually happened there and a
bunch of our work that is that is
documented there
and that starts with this memo and this
is the actual memo uh on March 14th that
I I was asked to write for the
California state government and
basically what they had said is hey we
know this is a there's something big
happening what should we do
and so we actually put down on paper
very quickly in the span of like an hour
and a half what we think the right plan
for California is and it's interesting
to take a look back when you're outside
the moment of crisis of what you write
in the moment of Crisis as your playbook
and for many of you it'll come as no
surprise what are the kind of key
components that we have to do first up
acquisition of timely data two cleaning
of the data three putting the data sets
together in a way that's usable a system
to look through for insights and then of
course you've got to be able to support
the traditional epidemiological models
and you've got to you've got to evaluate
those models as new data comes in and is
applied and so this is in many ways data
101 but there's another component about
this that became really important which
is actually how to put this together and
make this work and so very quickly what
we realized is there wasn't a team to do
this
and so one of the things that we did put
down was our first draft pick list all
the people that we thought were going to
be the most important people that we
could get together in short notice to
work on these problems and uh it's a
it's actually put down there in the last
paragraph of of those people uh of what
we thought was needed
and then the next at the end of the call
we said well who's going to do this and
we realized
no one else is coming it's up to us
we're the only people do it and so a
small band of us got together and
decided to head up there and decide to
say we are going to be that team that
put this together and so this is that
initial team that got together and so
those of you that have read premonition
you'll recognize the person in the
bottom right corner depending on which
way this screen is oriented for you or
the bottom left that's charity Dean
who's uh the epidemiologist featured in
the premonition
and this is us with Todd Park former U.S
CTO Bob kocher helped write the
Affordable Care Act Mike wilkining who
uh uh was former head of the the
Secretary of Health for the State of
California and Jenna who's now who
basically wrote the software for his
um the dragon space shuttle uh the
Dragon launch systems for for uh SpaceX
and this was a beginning core team that
we put together to try to identify what
would happen and what we thought would
could take place and we didn't start
like in the governor's office or
anything glorified this is in the way
back offices of the California
Department of of Technology uh and Amy
Tong allowed us to use his face as kind
of a a centering point where we could
start pulling all the data sets together
and start figuring out what's going on
and in this process what we realize as
we started to kind of go through this is
that we needed all these kind of core
elements to work together and as as we
kind of put in the memo this kind of
became the foundational Direction on
which we were building all our things
what could we model do we have models do
we have dashboards what would it take
for us to get dashboards about what's
going on data products what are the
things that we could produce to policy
makers to the public other types of
people
to figure out what we actually need to
do data catalogs data sets with those
data catalogs so that we can actually
make them usable and of course Data
Insights to make sure that we're getting
things working
and so one of the first things that we
realized was that we really didn't have
data or models and so one of the first
things that we looked at was is there an
epidemiological model that we could use
and it turned out there was a pretty
decent one that would work for the state
of California because many of these
models as many you know are pretty
simplistic and they follow some basic
rules but we need to do something a
little bit more complex for California
and so Justin leseder
um added John Hopkins at that time had
this epidemiological model but it was
really sitting on some basically on the
desktops of grad students and so we
needed to wait to get this to work to
run lots of simulations
and so I called in a favor to uh Werner
Vogel who is the CTO of Amazon and said
could I get some servers would you be
willing to give us some equipment
and then together with that team at
Amazon
couple data scientists uh Josh Wills who
had helped build stripe and been at
Hadoop uh Sam Shaw who is notable for
figuring out how to scale the LinkedIn
product that you see on LinkedIn and
Kent rodolfa who is kind of the guy
behind the scenes who figured out during
the Obama election strategy how to use
data to actually be effective
the three of them with Justin's team and
werner's team figured out how to take
this this model out of the desk out of
the realm of graduate work graduate
student work and lift and shift it to
full production gear in a matter of just
a couple days
and this whole effort is what produced
the fundamental underlying policy layer
for a California it allowed us to
actually build and iterate to against
different scenarios
and one of those outputs was this
initial model in this initial results
and these are what Gavin Newsom then
tweeted out about why we needed to
initially shut down the then and really
take the hard decision to actually move
to stay-at-home orders and I want to be
very clear at this point because there's
a lot of questions about was that the
right call
and here's the thing that's a challenge
for us as data scientists
you have to make a call
even if you decide not to do anything
that is a call and when you are faced in
that moment and you have very little
data and you have to make decisions you
have to ask what is on the line
and what would we realized what was on
the line wasn't just a model we were in
close contact with the teams that were
what was happening in New York as those
those Health Care Systems were being
absolutely devastated and we were losing
literally losing the lives of First
Responders we were in touch with the
teams in Italy as they were getting
destroyed and we realized that if we in
California
took that kind of hit
against our Health Care system if that
number of nurses
Physicians other caretakers died of
covid we would not be able to recover
our Health Care system for a long time
decades because that's how long it takes
to train people or move people back in
and so our goal at that point was buy
ourselves another day get more data in
and that is really kind of where we
realize we needed a different form of
things around data products and so one
of the first things that we built is we
had all these other models that people
were starting to build lots of people
from the community were starting to
build which was fantastic
was we had a way needed a way to put it
together so we built something called
Cal cat which is a California coveted
assessment tool and what we realized is
local policy makers people at the county
level didn't actually have a way of
putting all this data together for City
Council Members the public or to make it
digestible
and so we built this tool very quickly
this is mostly built by people at the
California uh in the California state
government and this team that put this
together
is the one that really understood what
does it mean for a health care policy
peoples to have something on which they
could make decisions and so we took a
whole bunch of work and we realized this
is what it needs to say if you have all
these Data Systems out there all these
other models all these things but how do
you actually make that data effective
making a singular model was not the most
important thing it was putting in a form
to help take data and move it to a place
where people could make a decision and
that was a key assessment in here
one of the things that we also did in
that time period was uh and cara de
fries had this really great idea is she
she put on the main California site
where we were getting proposing
California information about covet a
survey response and so we were getting
these survey responses back from people
and in that one of the things that came
back were all these great quotes about
what people were feeling how they were
this allowed us to take that data that
we were putting together all throughout
this the system this cow-cat system
and going to the local levels and
combine it with actual quotes and
feelings of what people were seeing on
the ground so it gave us a way of not
only taking the data that having the
data points but tethering it to real
true stories that were out there and
that grounding is what really made this
work
the other portion in here that we need
to talk about is data sets that was
amazing effort by so many people to
contribute data sets to the system but
one of the things that we found as that
was happening and this is a ques this is
a little funny cartoon that was put
together when I first took my role in at
the White House is we had all these data
sets come in and people were throwing
them into the databases we were doing a
great job in ingesting them putting them
in there but guess what wasn't happening
people weren't using the data people
were really great about acquiring data
but as many you know you get the data in
but nobody's using it it is not if you
build it they will come
and so one of the first things that we
had to do on this Lane of work
was put together the classic data
catalog now who's going to do that it
turned out there was nobody else to do
it except myself and two other people
from the California Department of
technology and so we wrote down and just
sort of went through and went through
each data set cataloged it and started
to ask how could we make this
discoverable how can we put it out there
now there's a lot of great technology
out there that's doing this but we
actually needed to open up even more and
so we literally what we did is we
created a little bit of a data book that
described what was in the data sets and
the kind of ideas that people could have
and that really started to help people
realize like oh I might be able to ask
other questions
and this is literally the example of
what that looked like and so why am I
telling you this because a lot of times
when we're in organizations and we're
working on these things in data
it's very easy to get frustrated or
pissed about what people are doing with
your data or not doing with your data
but it also shows that in these moments
it doesn't matter your level or who you
are sometimes what you have to do is
just fundamentally roll up your sleeves
and just do the work yourself and you
have to find a way to make this so easy
for others you have to lower the barrier
of entry for other people to work with
you or to build on things that you're
doing
and that kind of get came to the next
part which we realized is what would it
take to get insights and now one of the
beautiful things that was happening at
this time was the broad Community
efforts here we had so many many of you
out there who were helping on these
things but one of the things that we
realized is we needed a way to have a
team that all their job was to look at
this data to use that data that data
catalog and find interesting things we
put a team together of that that was led
by Cara diffrais we had people like
Roger magula so many of you know who
started the strata conference and others
all volunteer Force who came in and all
they did their job was to play with the
data they would come up and build these
data sets or to build these slides that
told a story
how to think about essential versus
non-essential employees how are people
traveling what's going on this got then
produced not in anything super fancy it
got turned into a slide deck that went
up every night to the leadership team of
California but not just California but
was shared very often with the governors
and mayors of not only California but
around the country and it gave people
visibility into what was happening
there was another key thing that was
here in this in every one of these decks
we always told the stories of real
people and how did we do that
it was because we had these quotes and
so we were tethering data with real
stories and that combination is what
allowed us to really be able to ground
this and what we found was more than the
models this Collective
storytelling this narrative helping
people sense around us this is what
helped the policy makers understand what
to do
my belief is there's no difference in
this when policy makers or people in a
company or a non-profit or anywhere else
this is what you have to put together to
get people to understand the richness of
problem or figure out what to do
now I need to call out also the
unbelievable effort that so many of you
have done
there with there was a component of this
that I've described is the work of
volunteers combined with the traditional
civil servants who really have done a
heroic effort on this that combination
making things happen
but I want you to think about the
massive volunteer army that was stood up
at this time around the world
you had groups like the kova tracking
project and covet act now who were
figuring out data and built
relationships at local hospitals around
the country around the world to then do
their own assessments to build their own
models
to make and find ways to leverage data
scientists to
LeapFrog the way we had thought about
handling a pandemic you had the U.S
digital response that was created to
work at the local level to help on
smaller issues a lot more local issues
around tracking of of cases finding
other issues think Legacy technology
that was preventing us from making sure
that people could get the services they
need
some of these actions revolved also
result resulted in the digital passports
the other aspects of being able to show
the information you've had you also had
academic programs that really stood up
one of the ones that I'm proud of here
in California is that we had created
across the University of California
systems all of them coming together
to continue to to pile their research
together to share learnings and to
figure out what do we do together
there's humanitarian efforts like Crisis
ready that put together how do we use
location data from cell phone tracking
ads other places in a privacy preserving
way a responsible manner to get an
assessment of what's taking place and
how to use that data to actually help
policy makers know what's going on
so the first lesson I would have for you
who is on your first draft list of
people you've heard me talk about a
whole bunch of people on this thing none
of this could have been done without
this whole team
and so if you were to write down and
you're faced with a crisis
who would be on your first draft list
what would their skills be
it's funny how often we'll ask this
question if we're a startup
or founding a team starting an open
source project
but what if there is this moment that
comes
who would be on your first list who are
those people that you know you could be
depending on
and the second part of this is what can
you do to be on someone else's first
draft list
you don't have to be the former U.S
Chief data scientist to be on someone's
first draft list you have to have added
value you have to be a great teammate
you have to have the raw skills to be
able to perform and be able to be
effective
but more than that
you have to be a good teammate that's
the first and foremost
two
it's the small things that cause the
biggest pain points
and as data people we all know this it's
a data cleaning it's the data catalogs
it's all these little things and so
focus on picking up the work of the
small things that will unlock
the limitations
that that are blocking other people from
doing the work
ask yourself what could you do that
would unlock the masses that would help
everyone else do their job what would
that look like
and don't be afraid to pick up that work
yourself there is no
work too small for any of us we all have
to do it
third the models without storytelling
just don't work
we've seen this and we have to be very
honest with ourselves at this point in
our society we've had models for a covid
and disease forecasting we saw this
during Ebola we've seen this during SARS
one we've seen it during MERS we've seen
it so many times and yet we have
incredible distrust around the models
the models also frankly were not able to
keep up with policy making questions
so they were deficient there
let's take another area where we've had
a real challenge with models and data
climate change
we have often thrown more and more data
more models and more evidence at the
public
and it has not worked
but you know what has
storytelling
telling the stories of real people how
it's going to impact them what do we
need to think about all of those
different challenges and so the models
without storytelling
don't work
and so if I had to pick I would say pick
storytelling over models and that may
seem strange to talk about storytelling
versus a data chart or something else
but that's the primary way this works
more effectively
Lesson Four
the data points have names
some of you have heard me say this
before I have to reiterate because the
number of times where somebody will show
me something
and if I ask them tell me a story about
one of those data points they can't
I've been so privileged to work on so
many interesting problems
the most rewarding thing I ha I can tell
you as a data scientist whether it was
building LinkedIn working on problems at
eBay building devoted health
working National Security issues
is honestly getting to know the stories
behind the people
their actual names
what they tell me
one of the most important calls I was
doing regularly in covid during covet
time period was talking to the
Physicians and the teams in the other
hospitals learning what it was really
like for them understanding from
patients what they really went through
what it meant and felt like as a as a
nurse in the ICU
you have to learn their stories
it's your responsibility when you learn
their stories to tell their stories
if you put up a graph and you aren't
telling their stories
it's almost like we're taking advantage
of them
but we're not being responsible
for really
what they've given us as their data
and so learn their stories tell their
stories
part I want to emphasize here is that
data science is a team sport
none of this project
this effort would have worked if we
didn't do it as a team
if charity wasn't there if Cara wasn't
there if Jenna wasn't there Todd Bob
Mike wilkining
Justin Lesnar Warner Vogel and his team
you name it Roger all of them
Amy Tong
UE wouldn't work
it's a team sport
certainly these projects like the covet
tracking project covetak now us digital
Response Code for America
there are all efforts that work because
it's a team
and so remember that this is a team
and one of the things about being on a
team is being a good team mate
and so what does that mean to be a good
teammate none of us got here just
because uh on our own on our own skills
I certainly didn't
I got here because people gave me a
chance remember I'm the guy who really
didn't get into college I went to
Community College people had to give me
a shot at doing things
so I would ask
who could you give in
who could you give a chance to
maybe there's out there someone who's
left a question out there on a forum
they're looking for an answer they're
looking for someone to give them a
little bit of time a little bit of help
what if you did that
what if you just opened up
a little bit of time on your calendar to
try to help somebody
maybe you need help
maybe you need your suffering in silence
what would it look like for you to ask
for help
find people who are going to be a good
teammate for you a supportive team for
you
and I want to end with a card that
President Obama gave me which I think is
really important especially as we think
about data the times we live in
and the world all together
everything we do
everything we do needs to be infused
with a sense of possibility we are not
scared of the future
everything we do needs to be infused
with a sense of possibility we are not
scared of the future
this
I think summarizes how we need to
approach data
technology our responsibilities to each
other
it's very easy to look at a problem and
say wow that's too hard or be so
frustrated with it or just challenged
and it's it's just easy to be a hater
these days
what I'd rather approach us and what I
believe is a community what I
fundamentally believe for us as a
community
is that this community and the data
Community works and has had the impact
that it has across Society across the
world and will continue to do so because
we believe
in that sense of possibility
we are not scared of the future we
Embrace a future
there are extraordinary challenges
coming up but we are not scared to take
them on we do the hard work we roll up
our sleeves we do it as a team and we
challenge it all together that's what it
takes to do for us to do all these
things
and let me finally end with this card
that's taken off a life of its own since
I posted it for uh back when I was in
the White House and this is a card I
wrote in a very challenging time
a time where we were dealing with the
murder of Michael Brown and seeing the
impact in Ferguson and really
confronting the the fundamental
challenges in our policing both for
officers who put their lives on the line
and those in the community who have
suffered
one of the things in that moment was
what does it look like
to really find a path forward to not be
afraid of the future to challenge
ourselves and this is what I wrote on
that that card
as a strategy for us to do that and this
was done in conjunction with a number of
chiefs of police around the United
States Civic technologists activists and
the strategy was
let's break this apart and ask what
could we do so that we dream in years
plan in months evaluate in weeks but
let's always find a way to ship
something daily let's find a way to
create a path for Progress daily we may
shift something and then roll it back we
may take it realize we didn't do it
quite right but we are always doing
something daily
let's figure out a way we could
prototype this for 1X build for 10x
integer for 100x maybe we try it in one
town then we do it across the whole
state and then across the country of the
world
maybe we do it or build this prototype
and we test it beta tested with a small
population to see if it helps then we
kind of do a little bit larger and
finally realize we have something that
can scale
it's no different than an open source
project
and then asking ourselves what could we
do to cut the timeline in half while
doubling the impact we want to cut the
timeline in half and double the impact
let's put ourselves on an exponential
trajectory of product development for
our projects that then fundamentally
changes the way we kind of can approach
all these different projects and
fundamentally believe we are going to
have the impact that I know we can have
as a community
and so let me stop there and happy to
take questions however we do them but
one of the things if I if I can end on
this is I just want to say thank you to
this community and and
when these problems have happened in our
society
you all are the community that has
contributed your time your energy your
passion and so many of these problems
that that I've been fortunate enough to
work on
you all have been there to enable this
so it's been very hard in these times to
find a way to figure out how to say
thank you directly
and so hopefully this is a moment where
I get to say thank you for all of you
that have done this work thank you that
are still working on different elements
and thank you for those that are going
to continue in different ways finding
different ways to put this work in I
know it's a sacrifice not just for you
financially economically time wise but
also it's a stress on your families for
the amount of long hours that you put on
this
and so thank you for doing that and
thank you to your families for allowing
you to work on these projects
all right Dave how do we want to run
this so I think what we'll do is we're
going to open the floor up for Q a
um so we already have a few questions
trickling in so the first question comes
from rishika rupam
and what she was asking is you know
through the course of this project
um was there something that you believed
before that fundamentally changed during
that time
um and just how did that change your
thinking
yeah
um uh rishika this is a great question
so I can't tell you the the best thing
is when I feel like I'm changing my mind
hourly during these things rather than
over a whole project the fundamental
learning that happened on these projects
was I thought I had understood one thing
in the morning and by the evening we
were regrouping as a team and realizing
actually this is quite different for us
and we did stand ups twice a day morning
evening to try to say what are we
learning but if I had to take one that
was Major For Me overall
was I came to this problem believing
that models could carry us much further
into policy making and decision making
than it did
and that was a tough that was a tough
lesson for me because I come from very
much from that modeling background that
was really important to me
and what I found was policy makers would
ask questions like well what happens if
we shut down schools
what would it take for us to get back
the schools opening up and then if we
ask those questions from the modeling we
realized we were just deficient and so
what it proved to me was
we not only need to massively invest in
our modeling efforts but our overall
data infrastructure to better answer
these type of questions this is one of
the reasons I'm really excited about the
standing up of the national disease
forecasting Center at the Centers for
Disease Control and I believe we need
equivalent kind of effort across the
world
just like we shared data very openly
around weather
that's and that's not seen as political
if I share weather data we need that
same approach to happen around disease
surveillance and as climate change
happens and we see more viruses changing
from you know disease reservoirs as we
get you know encroachment into regions
where we see the permafrost melt this is
going to be essential for us to be able
to have is this combination of modeling
bringing the data into some of the data
simulation pulling it in but also being
able to do the policy making
another component of this that I believe
is fundamental is
the
in the public policy schools where many
public policy people are trained they
not only we've been focusing on training
them on on technology why technology is
important in the policy making process
we now need to also help people really
understand the better use of data we've
taught them basic statistics we need now
we need to jump them forward to proper
data science and use of that data but
also as we think about the increasing
impacts around machine learning AI other
areas to help them understand the
challenges and how to interpret the
results more effectively
right so the next question
um comes from
Georgian feitzma
um
and he asked looking back can you say
something about the quality of the data
that you've used in your models
yeah hopefully I'm saying this right
you're again uh or your Jinn uh
apologies otherwise tweet at me and tell
me properly how to how to pronounce it
uh so the quality of the models I think
there's a few things the first part is
that we didn't have enough data the
limits of data the ability to have it
and fundamentally one of the issues at
hand here was a lack of testing early on
in the pandemic we just couldn't get
data people didn't even have the access
to tests and remember those those days
where there was long long lines around
these centers what people were like
doing drive-through swabs then we ran
out of PCR reagent to be able to do
those tests to do the PCR tests and so
basically we didn't have data signal we
were trying to guess
and then there was another component
that we've learned since then around
covet which is that if you look at the
genetic sampling and we weren't doing
good forensics is covet had been
circulating in the population for
significantly longer or earlier than we
realized and so we were working with
such imperfect data that we were trying
to run simulations with uh these huge
huge error bars from the initial data
set while also trying to run many
simulations about shutting down schools
closing down you know do you allow
essential workers to open restaurants
all of these things because so many
people are impacted by these decisions
uh the other thing that we were dealing
with in this time period was the
politicalization around a lot of this
data particularly out of China so we
weren't getting the most up-to-date data
signals that that were there what was
stood up were these different channels
digital channels on you know signal
WhatsApp Discord slack channels where
people were sharing their own data from
their local hospitals and that data was
pretty good but even in the data that
was coming from the hospitals
this data infrastructure was woefully
lacking
the data that you would get from What's
called the data the hospital census in
the morning the number of people who
were in the ICU the number of beds you
might get four hours later very
different and you're like how could this
happen and it realized that inside the
hospital
despite the amount of investment roughly
30 billion dollars in the U.S to make
digital electronic medical records
happen people still had a lot of
difficulty just tracking how many people
were in the ICU with covid and then as
many people have heard there's a
fundamental question around mortality
which was did this person die because of
covid did they die
um you know it just happened that they
they had some other eggs issue and covid
was the secondary or tertiary thing and
and in this part I need to also point
out you know a lot of people have
debated about covid
and about the policies it is important
to always highlight that the United
States in itself has had more than a
million people who have lost their lives
from covid it's estimated that long
covet is going to cost more than 3
trillion to the U.S economy over the
next several years and that's just in
the U.S Spectrum it's not even talking
about the massive impact it has had in
other countries and continues to have
due to vaccine pricing access to
vaccines and other questions that that
are out there as well as what I believe
is going to be the longer term impact
that we still don't have data signal on
specifically as vaccine hesitancy
happens to child to children at uh um
you know for polio or or other type of
diseases that they should be inoculated
against in the first several years of of
life
oh Dave I think you're on you
thank you uh also one of the lessons
we've all learned during covid exactly
exactly it's very talkative to this next
question uh from Matthew looking back is
there anything you had wish you did
differently
oh Matthew
I I mean the number of decisions I wish
I had back it could fill would fill
bucks uh
you know one of the things that I've
learned in this moment and and I really
learned this from President Obama and
both former secretary uh the late former
secretary Ash Carter
is that
the thing that you get is is
when you're at some of these problems
your job
you just have to make a decision and
you're you there is no good answer the
only thing that is a is a bad answer is
not taking action
and in the case of California for
example it was to take that that we
needed if we didn't take action losing
those kind of Physicians those nurses
the nurse practitioners the the
janitorial staff the other essential
workers in the Health Care system
that would have a massive long-term
repercussions
some of the things that I wish
concretely
that we had done better is done a better
job of advocating to the public health
officials why greater Nuance was needed
around questions about what is open and
what isn't for example closing down the
beaches in Southern California makes
sense predominantly because of the
number of bars and the the
infrastructure around the beaches it
does not make sense in Northern
California where it's wide open and
empty I think the need for kids to be
back in school in education
is really critical and now we're seeing
the results the beginning results of
that and it's been devastating uh uh on
kids uh both mental health-wise as well
as education wise
at the same time I still don't think we
have done a great post-mortem on covid
about data infrastructure and figuring
out what we actually need to do as a
Playbook
that is still open
I still wish we had found ways to keep
the infrastructure of the covet tracking
project up and running and handed off
more smoothly back to CBC
I wish that there was a better way to
activate the community and take all the
input in so that it doesn't have to be a
small team but it can be the Army and
masses of all the people out there to
come in and support projects like this
it should not rest on a small team of
individuals it needs to be a broad
Community basis and we need to figure
out how to better activate and leverage
the community overall and that's just a
few but
like we've done the several look backs
and boy do I wish I had so many
decisions back uh
I wish I had taken more caffeine with me
uh while we were doing this and even
stupid stuff I can't like you know
remember this is a time where
we're operating on such imperfect
information that when we were doing that
as I showed you that picture we weren't
wearing masks because we thought it was
surface born we literally we were
washing our hands so often that everyone
had Burns uh chemical burns on their
hands from overuse of sanitizer yet we
weren't wearing masks
and so just our basic hygiene wasn't
wasn't necessary it wasn't appropriate
and it's just a miracle that we didn't
we didn't get people sick or lose people
because this was a type of time where it
was pre-vaccine but I will tell you one
that I think is really that I'm proud of
is remember the investments in these
vaccines that we have seen
the ones that have been predominantly
the most effective the RNA path forms
these aren't just Miracle things that
happened overnight these are long-term
Investments more than a decade ago by
the Department of Defense the National
Institutes of Health and many
collaborations with Academia to do this
and so those long-term Investments many
of those are the ones that we need to
seed now to prepare us for the next set
of challenges not only on public health
but in all areas energy water issues
climate issues
environmental concerns net we need to
make those Investments now
and so
um we have another question from Cassie
Whitehall
um who asks what are the differences in
the mindsets and practices that you have
seen between doing data science in
Industry versus when you're working for
the US government yeah great question
Cassie so you know there it's really
interesting uh
there it's actually way I would
characterize it is it's almost more
specific to
who you're working with rather than one
industry or another I've seen Parts in
the government where you would think oh
boy this is going to be so incredibly
difficult
problems that you would think would be
you know just impossible to take on move
super easily and why because you have a
president that cares take take the idea
of genomic medicine and really having
tailored genomic treatments that was a
passion area for president uh for
President Obama it is a passion area for
them vice president now president uh um
Biden those areas once that happens
opens up the opportunity to do so much
good work I've also seen play areas in
companies where companies are totally
you know they're just unwilling to Value
the data scientists or what they can do
with the data and as a result
they they miss the opportunity
uh I've seen places where things are
open
and and non-profits where groups like
Crisis text line are fundamentally using
data in innovating in novel ways
if there's one common thread
that I would encourage all of you just
to to do so
wherever you work maybe here's a few
common areas number one is what to look
for in a data team or a place to go do
you have the ability to have a seat at
the table
that places where you have a seat at the
table are critical it's funny in how
many companies you have that are data
oriented but there's no data scientist
in the leadership room
that's kind of crazy the equivalent of
that to me is like if you were on the
bridge of the Starship Enterprise and
there's no Spock like what depends which
version you're on but I guess our data
on the bridge if you're in Picard times
the the
the component there is you need someone
at the table this is why the role of the
US Chief data scientist was created what
President Obama realized is that there
has to not only be a U.S Chief
technology officer somebody who's going
to help give the president direct advice
on how to think about technological
issues you need a person there next to
the president
giving her or him advice on how to think
about the best use of data the
responsible and that is actually in fact
why the mission of the deep data
scientist is to responsibly Unleash the
Power of data to benefit all Americans
and you can argue that should be done in
across the whole world for all Humanity
in companies non-profits of that the
biggest thing that prevents data
scientists from being effective is
holding them back preventing them in the
room saying sorry this room is only for
leaders
if you're in an organization where
that's culturally that the data
scientists are relegated to the back
office or the back room and not allowed
to be in that decision-making process
that's a problem
if they're unwilling to do to allow that
to happen
then I hate to say it that is culturally
broken at that moment and you need to
find a way either that's going to be
fixed or go to a place where that is
part of the culture and the places that
I work with the places I go the cultures
I try to implement and the organizations
that I get to to help build from from
day Zero those all have that core tenet
at hand
so we have about 10 minutes left so
we're probably getting near the end of
the Q a
um and for these last 10 minutes what we
wanted to do was to try a little bit of
an experiment
um so one of the major themes of Pi data
2022 has been the power of analytics and
data science in the open source
Community as well as the variety of ways
that it can help us solve different
challenges
um to celebrate that we actually have a
series of questions that were generated
by an AI chatbot so uh if you're willing
to play along yeah we have a couple of
them don't worry I have my chat bot here
yeah exactly uh
um so the first question
um is uh kind of a softball how did you
become interested in data science
um and what motivates you to continue
working in the field
so what motivated me work on data
Sciences in is I was an extremely poor
student in the classroom but I really
loved trying to understand
how the world worked and why the world
worked certain ways I fell in love with
this idea of something called chaos
there nonlinear Dynamics
when I was uh
really a 10th grader in in high school
but I didn't have the math to do it and
so I started to really try to see like
what could I do to understand the world
and the and when I got to college I
realized like hey I could combine this
math thing because data sets were now
being opened up
and what I realized what excited me
personally was being able to find a data
set be able to go through it and find
and discover an Insight that people
hadn't seen
I think of it's very much like an
Explorer and that what I felt like in
those moments when it was like three in
the morning and I'm crawling through a
data set and you see something that
you've produced and you're like whoa
I imagine that must have been like what
it was like as an Explorer seeing a
continent for the first time or
discovering a new plant or animal
you're seeing something that no one else
has seen before
that same feeling is still what makes it
so beautiful for me even in the covet
response like when we produce those
models for the first time and we were
like uh oh
it still was a moment of like wow
it was a moment of like no one actually
has seen this no one has done this
and and that
you know one giant leap for mankind kind
of moment you know to take the Armstrong
quote
that that felt like that's what it feels
like with data for me that's what it
feels is that that moment of discovery
that moment of invention we get as an
open source Community to be at the
Forefront
of seeing things that nobody else has
seen I am so excited like for about
things like drug Discovery where people
are about to discover new things or even
in this case the melding of AI to
discover make new fundamental
breakthroughs that no one has understood
or seen that to me is astonishing and so
exciting the only question is how do we
make sure we do it in that responsible
way as as a community
awesome
uh the next question is in your mind
what do you think your most significant
contribution to the field of data
science has been
uh
I think it's actually not me
I think if anything my most significant
contribution I think I get too much
credit
um very honestly I think it's about the
team
uh you know even the story of how we
came up with the term data scientists
and that's a term that's been used
before and kind of had faded out and
kind of rediscovered but Monica regatti
and some of you heard me talk about that
I have how she kind of had this idea of
testing that term at LinkedIn and we
realized oh that that worked
uh Jonathan Goldman doing his work
initially on people we may know all the
people like kit rodofa Sam Shaw Josh
will Justin Cherry all of them all those
people uh giving them voice and being
able to share that lane
the the fact that I was Chief data
scientist
the first one is should be a less of a
reflection of me and more of a
reflection that we got here as a
community and I just had the honor and
privilege to be able to help take that
baton or create that baton
for that moment in time for that role
that baton has been passed it's now
Denise Rosses who's the current U.S
Chief data scientist and then she will
pass it to somebody else and that will
get passed to somebody else
and so what I think of as data science
here and hopefully what I've been able
to contribute to us as is that
responsibility for us to have that ethos
that we are supposed to think of this as
a relay and pass it from one team to
another as we move forward on our
Journeys as not only as individuals but
as teams and as Society
thank you and um we're now at the five
minute Mark but I think there's enough
time for one more question
um which is what do you think the most
significant Trends and developments in
the open source and data science
ecosystem are and how do you think
they'll impact the future
so one of the biggest challenges we have
right now in open source is open source
in the sense of like there's so much
open source
how do we
it used to be early on in open source
was really easy to create
you know sort of a project and decide if
it fit and made sense for other people
it either blossomed massively or died
when we started the Kafka project that
that was became immediately evident but
we had other projects like Voldemort
which is a key value store that sort of
did really well initially and then faded
out but you saw this with other areas
like hbase and different projects like
um Hadoop now there's a lot of choice
there's a few things I think which make
that difficult which is it's still
really hard for somebody who comes in to
kind of know like what is what should I
work on which projects are there
we've had a challenge of how do we make
sure that we are a massively inclusive
community and culture and I'm making I'm
making very broad generalizations here
of things that we need to make sure we
do
and then the part here is is
how do you how do we stitch different
pieces because one of the things that I
think we have a challenge of in open
source is as an open source project goes
on some things that are supposed to be
single use or very narrow I think of it
as a toolbox the hammer should be a
hammer and very often in open source
sometimes it suddenly a hammer turns
into a Swiss army knife and it becomes
like all these other things and then
you're like oh what do we do
so I also would love to see a model
where we take lessons from the old
and apply them and reinvent them like
some of the original time scheduler
projects like oscarbon and others those
came from those time scheduling problems
and solutions came from the original
computer kind of time sharing models of
you know pre-pdp 11 kind of days that
early compute and if you talk to like I
think there's a version like where we
don't always have to reinvent the wheel
but we can take other things that we
have and upgrade them and then the other
one which I think when this is one of
the reasons why I think this event is so
important is we need to find ways to get
together more often and talk
and share as a community
the data science movement was really
born out of people getting together
regularly
and that just happened to be football at
LinkedIn and Facebook and others getting
together rather regularly we don't have
some of those other previous events like
strata conference or others anymore and
so we need and a lot of these have been
co-opted by companies like they're now
you can go to Amazon revamp and not
making a judgment on these companies
it's more of a function of like where
are the fundamental ones like where we
get together as a team and talk through
where do we want to go from here what
projects do we need all those components
and then the last one I would just leave
with
is what does it look like for us to kind
of say to a company organization like
hey these are the set of Technologies
you should use all together
and also what does a career path look
like how do we make sure that as people
work on these projects they get their
credit
they get the credit due for them so just
like in the same way like you get you
know a college degree and you're like oh
yeah you get you got a master's in
physics we know what that means there's
equivalence here of like you should have
a masters or a doctorate because you
worked on some of these projects you
should get that certification you should
get that credit and that should go on
your LinkedIn profile your CV or your
resume and that once you've shown that
you've done that level of contribution I
think benefits not only the individual
but gives credibility to the the
the broader Community overall
thank you so much and um with that I
think we are out of time but I just
wanted to say it was a real pleasure to
have you here and it was really amazing
to hear from you and to learn about
everything that you did during the
pandemic thank you Dave and and thank
you for organizing this and all the it
is I know how much work it is to pull
these off so thank you to the team for
for getting this group together and and
all of you who are working on these many
many different open source projects
thank you for putting all that time and
energy into it I really can't stress
enough how how appreciative I am